weyergraf entlässt bundesratskandidatin
viola amherd aus dem hearing
sie wurde soeben von der frauen lobby in
die mangel genommen
ihrer konkurrentin heidis karten steht
das hearing noch bevor
auch karin keller-sutter musste rede und
antwort stehen
sie ist die dritte frau im rennen um den
bundesratssitz
der einzige männliche kandidat ist hans
wicki
zur auswahl stehen drei frauen und nur
ein mann
zufall oder bravourstück der frauen
lobby auf der suche nach einer antwort
hefte ich mich an maria grafs fersen
sie gehört zu den frontfrauen der
bundeshaus feministinnen man erst der
eindruck die frau ist verdammt schnell
unterwegs sind brauchen wir jedenfalls
braucht hartnäckigkeit und locker
schwierige kombination
[Musik]
sie wissen wir können es kurz machen
einmal mehr hat es keine frau in den
bundestag geschafft er heraus wurde
gewählt bereits vor einem jahr machen
die co präsidentinnen maya graf und
kathrin bertschy an der
präsidentenkonferenz des frauen
dachverbandes alliance f mobil mehr
frauen in den bundesrat
bislang hatte die schweiz 110 bundesräte
und nur sieben bundesrätinnen eine
magere bilanz
die bundesrätin
beim fototermin mit bundesrätin
simonetta sommaruga alles frauen aber
auch nur für das bild das bundeshaus ist
ein männer laden weyergraf und ihre
mitstreiterinnen wollen das nachhaltig
ändern
[Musik]
chemie qualitativ die besten sieben mal
sieben tolle an sich noch nicht so weise
die standorte auf menschheit vermischtes
gerechtigkeit alle ganz wichtiges presse
bevölkerung von mercedes klar weniger
wert sind
frauenpower und frauensolidarität diese
parolen höre ich während meiner
dreharbeiten immer wieder existiert so
was wie ein wir-gefühl unter
spitzenpolitikerinnen ich begleite maya
graf in ihrem bundeshaus alltag
frauenpolitik das heißt natürlich nicht
nur bundesratskandidaten befragen
es ist ein hartes stück arbeit meyer
graf alt gerade an ihrem vorstoß zur
erhaltung des kosten archiv eine
sammlung von wertvollen dokumente zur
geschichte der frauenbewegung der
stiftung geht das geld aus während die
politische geschichte der männer in
staatlichen archiven untergebracht ist
ist jene der frauen privatsache
weyergraf will zusammen mit fünf
ratskolleginnen das archiv retten
eine davon susanne leutenegger
oberholzer
las ich dass ich hier das erwähnte bild
auf twitter
die beiden nationalrätinnen reißen sich
für die gemeinsame sache zusammen es
kriselt wie im gespräch mit susanne
leutenegger oberholzer erfahre
am wochenende sei sie für das gemeinsame
anliegen allein unterwegs gewesen und
fühle sich von den ratskolleginnen im
stich gelassen
sie macht hat sie die europa zählt der
frauenpolitik
zufall oder nicht bei der anschließenden
besprechung der frauen fehlt susanne
leutenegger oberholzer
die restlichen nationalrätinnen jede aus
einer anderen partei demonstrieren
einigkeit gemeinsam wollen sie eine
mehrheit schaffen
das ist in ihrem todestag zeigt sie ohne
kenntnis der geschichte gibt es kein
solches sind sie feministin ich sagen
immer ich bin lieber recovery für
kollege von der frau und die situation
da natürlich alles in allem so eine
komfortable situation ist das aber eine
ganz frische mal vielleicht user halten
mit mehr gelassenheit würde sinn machen
in düsseldorf findet kolja wenig
moderner
so trinken das ist bitter wenn man immer
unerwähnt dass man wasser trinken freuen
wenn man jetzt alles klar nachdem
sprache ja das kommt ja gut
genau wie signal also klar
der nationalrat hat die fünf
gleichlautenden vorstöße der frauen
angenommen
sehr zur freude der
interessengemeinschaft der kosten
stiftung
trotz allem zwischen meyer graf und
susanne leutenegger oberholzer herrscht
immer noch dicke luft das spürt man
deshalb hab ich später noch einmal nach
stichwort frauensolidarität geht es dir
darin wirklich oder sind eben frauen der
partei oder sich selber ich muss jetzt
vorschlagen wie sie mit dem zug kommen
oder bei bema november das hockern
gebrochen und die harten
auseinandersetzungen und seen und der
stadtrat antwortzeit verständlich diese
frauen eine mit einige überfordern
übrigens mein mann ist sich nicht einig
systeme stärken wenn frauen ist ziemlich
hart
die politik schafft die spielregeln
unserer gesellschaft und ich frage mich
bin ich aus frau hier gut vertreten
schließlich beträgt der weibliche anteil
im nationalrat gerade mal 30 prozent im
ständerat ist der anteil der frauen noch
tiefer für eine gleichstellung bräuchte
es eindeutig mehr frauen in
entscheidungsgremien in der
bundesrätinnen frage will maya graf
endlich nägel mit köpfen machen
aber wie das zeigt sie mir anhand der
für heute geplanten aktion
die akkus die unterstützung steht schon
parat schwierig
die rede ist von der bevorstehenden
debatte maya graf hat einen vorstoss
eingereicht die nationalrätin will eine
angemessene vertretung beider
geschlechter im bundesrat per verfassung
regeln
wiesberger bevor es losgeht haben ja
schon länger film muss ich sie nun ihr
gefragt und warum sind sie eigentlich
feministin wurden
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das heißt ich mich eigentlich fertig und
vor allem gleichberechtigt und durch
doch schon älter bin schon eine tochter
habe jetzt über 20 ist finde ich das
eigentlich verrückt der stimmen
das kampftraining behalten holz macht
auch oder parteien und lacht hatif
ordnet sich dankte den am haut gebracht
es ist schon so dass zusammen oder quote
mit sechs wie es eine ganze kompetenz
haben wir das jetzt fordere
sowas passiert schlicht mit besteht
gefahr dass man nachher ewig sich
aufgrund von quote ticket gewählt wurde
also ganz ehrlich zeitlich wird aufgrund
von quote ticket auf gar nicht einfach
in die reihen
bevor es in der kommission hart auf hart
geht wird medienwirksam die werbetrommel
gerührt mit bundesrätinnen trikots für
eine gemischte mannschaft
[Applaus]
silber holte mit dem zutritt verboten
während die kommission debattiert mache
ich mir gedanken zum steg markt der
toten frau senken von den männern hier
nur die besten drin eben um es kurz zu
machen meyer grafs vorstoß wird von der
kommission abgelehnt auch von frauen
sie hatte gestimmt
frau sie ist schnitts maßgebende
kriterium
und ich weiß aus eigener erfahrung ich
bin ja schon seit jahren im parlament
frauen wenig wobei der svp politisiert
die hand überhaupt keine unterstützung
von der feministinnen und im garten
vielmehr werde damit flacht macht und
südzucker gesucht sondern feminismus ist
aber nicht wertneutral sondern richtet
sich vor allem an die frauen im linken
spektrum 2010 fördert ja ich habe einen
wirklich gut auch der frauen wenn sie
überstunden auswählen und einfach froh
dass dann keine frauensolidarität leider
nicht so funktionieren
er wünschte dass die spiele aber
bundesratswahlen frauen verschiedener
verbände und organisationen haben sich
im bundeshaus eingefunden
der ständerat stimmt heute über
maßnahmen zur lohngleichheit ab weil
frauen noch immer weniger als männer
verdienen würden wollen sie mit ihrer
präsenz druck ausüben und war im
ständerat nicht bei allen abstimmungen
veröffentlicht wird wer wie stimmt
nehmen die frauen die parlamentarier ins
visier
mit hilfe einer sitzordnung
weil sie das gefühl die ständeräte fluss
dass die norge dürfen die tribünen und
dank hat okay das sind traurig stimme
anders ich hoffe dass sie das natürlich
dass ich sehe deutschland in trance also
das war mito machen wird beobachtet
sowie die frauen oben auf der tribüne
wollen auch die nationalrätinnen mit
ihrer anwesenheit im ständeratssaal ein
zeichen setzen für mich ist es auch klar
dass diese vorlage und dieses gesetz
eingesetzt ist dass es nicht braucht die
wirtschaft hat die zeichen der zeit und
das potenzial von frauen längstens
erkannt und handelt auch entsprechend
wir stellen viele ungerechtigkeiten fest
lohnungleichheiten gibt es innerhalb der
branchen das wird als gottgegeben
angenommen ist auch so zu akzeptieren
das ist ein teil unserer
wirtschaftlichen freiheit dafür einen
kurzen schritt zurück machen denn in der
ganzen debatte scheint es bisher als
sakrosankte prämisse zu gelten dass eine
lohndifferenz die wir nicht erklären
können automatisch diskriminierend sei
das ist ein logischer fehlschluss
es geht um frauenanliegen abstimmen tun
aber hauptsächlich männer 39 und genau
zu sein frauen gibt es im ständerat
gerade mal 7
das geschäft wird zurück in die
kommission geschickt
es ist einfach wer das nur von
staatlichen stellen und zu sagen ja es
ist uns erneut ein dämpfer doch so
schnell geben die frauen nicht auf die
notizen werden eingesammelt die
retourkutsche kompost wenden per tweet
die mitteilung diese männer blockieren
maßnahmen zur lohngleichheit die herren
ständeräte am pranger
dass sie da auf der liste sind nicht
mein stein der ort läuft erstmal jetzt
druck größer das könnte zur politik was
mager sieht die kampf für sich immer ein
fenster populistisch oder um sich seine
frau politikum würdig wieder
verschlechtert ist haben sie dann
einfach stehen
die frau erhält vergleich gott und ich
betrachte das recht erkämpft werden
rechte kriegt man nicht geschenkt
die liste es hätte gar das stimmt ja
nicht geschickt
ständerat andrea caroni erzählt passend
zum thema wie er findet einen frauen
wächst vor der kamera will er diesen
aber nicht wiederholen
sehen sie sich auf der liste also es
sind sehr viele frauen auf der
zuschauertribüne sie nationalrätinnen im
saal bio im ständerat kann sie das wort
noch einige wackler so erlebe ja davor
im kreis der verträge den parlamenten
danceclub politikerin sind doch keine
filme freuen und nationalparks ich freue
mich immer die alten kolleginnen und
kollegen ständerat hat sehr wenig frage
aber es hat aber nie bewegt bienen
sie können ja hoffen die retter vor dass
ich immer genauso abstimmen wie die
trierer denke darum hinter mir stelle
sich der sondern bin ich mir das
vertiefte verstaubt der macho oder
feminismus freundlicher reform eine
sache des politischen lagers oder eine
generationenfrage
da fällt gold fdp-ständerat aus
neuchatel und feminist ähnlich wie maya
graf so hat auch er einen vorstoss zur
frauenquote im bundesrat eingereicht
allerdings im ständerat
im gegensatz zu meier graf hat fällt
kommt gepunktet
sollte meine brille anziehen und warum
haben sie überhaupt jetzt aus man sich
dafür eingesetzt
also für mich die gleichheit zwischen
mann und frau ist
frauenfrage das betrieb die die ganze
gesellschaft und was man tue ich mich ja
auch betroffen
dieser freitag ich denke es geht doch
eine änderung der mentalität der langsam
aber da was kommt ist es nicht
frustrierend jetzt manier frauen immer
dran sind und dann kommt ein junger mann
und schotter richtig und vor allem
[Musik]
anscheinend braucht es beide
geschlechter knapp ein halbes jahr
später komme ich wieder ins bundeshaus
der ständerat stimmte im zweiten anlauf
maßnahmen zur lohngleichheit zu auch der
nationalrat hat die vorlage angenommen
allerdings in einer abgeschwächten form
dem bundeshaus feministinnen ist in
diesem jahr kein großer wurf gelungen
aber die summe macht's aus die mediale
aufmerksamkeit der permanente druck auch
von der gesellschaft die parteien kommen
um die frauenfrage nicht mehr herum
das zeigt auch die wahl der nominierten
bundesratskandidaten doch wie viele
frauen sollen es dann im siebnergremium
sein
auch massa vertreter heißt entweder vier
oder drei oder wachsen also drei oder
vier
und so dreht sich das minimum das ist
mir eigentlich egal für frauen das
sollte den bundesrat sie sich mal vor
man im bundesrat einigen ob ich für
frauen sollten im bundesrat november
2008 10 die szene wiederholt sich
fototermin der frauen mit der
bundesrätin diesmal mit doris leute was
den fototermin vom kommenden jahr
anbelangt für nachschub ist bereits
gesorgt
[Musik]
publicis
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
gut und bitte ein bisschen animation
[Gelächter]